ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the ultimate Florida man
[Applause]
a viral video showing an MMA fighter and
Veteran wrestling a 10-foot alligator
outside an elementary school in Florida
don't worry he's a licensed Gator
Trapper so he knows what he's doing Greg
did you know that Gator Trapper was
something you could be licensed for I
had no idea
um big deal
really that was that was that makes it
in fastest to some dude
I mean are we running
we can't find I mean come on by the way
this was a setup I mean you don't just
run into a gator like a gator Trapper
just runs into a gator I think we're
being played I don't even think that's a
real Gator oh my God I don't think it is
I think it's inflated and I know my
inflatable Gators maybe it's artificial
that's like the sandbag
staged like the moon landing Jesse do
you believe that's a real alligator I do
because that guy is going to be on my
show tonight
he's going to be wrestling an alligator
live on Jesse Waters Prime Greg thinks
it's a Non-Stop I think it was stage
like the Moonlight I will I think he
should be in this they should send him
right to the swamp and get do his work
uh that's a real Gator and that's a real
man I'll say that there you go but but
we're also in their home too so
hopefully he wrestled him and put him
back in the water we're actually dating
can you ask him
yeah I'll say is that a real Gator Greg
wants to know and then Sandra wants to
know what'd you do with this thing yeah
yeah what kind of animal are you was he
okay hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else